oh oh let's do it okay my head is going
to explode that's right happy Wednesday
everybody you look fantastic as do I
so let's talk about Stanford some call
it a college although now it appears to
be a little more than a daycare center
for brain dead gas bags
it kicked off last week when the fifth
Circuit Judge Kyle Duncan was invited
remember that word invited by the
Stanford law school Federalist Society
to give a speech but when he started
this happened
and I'm just asking for an administrator
[Music]
you know keep in mind these aren't
kindergarteners with poopy pants these
are Stanford law students with
Poopypants but their deemed is worse a
giant sack of poopy pants if you will
I'm uncomfortable because this event is
tearing at the fabric of this community
that I care about and I'm here to
support I have to ask myself and I'm not
aesthetic to ask this is the juice worth
the squeeze and it's uncomfortable to
say this to you as a person it's
uncomfortable to say that for many
people here your work has caused harm oh
shut up
so
she's the victim or at least playing one
because that's her job after all she's
Tyran Steinbach Stanford's associate
Dean for you guessed it diversity equity
and inclusion although it should really
be diversity inclusion and Equity
because that would be d-i-e which is
what she wants all successful people to
do die
because it's all about Equity the idea
that no matter how hard you work and how
talented you are you won't and should
not get ahead of anyone else the left is
always changing words because we used to
call that communism to Stanford's credit
the president in law school dean then
apologized to the judge for what the
judge had called deeply uncivilable
Behavior by bullies so guess what
happened next the same students who
harassed the judge are now harassing the
administrators they're protesting
apologies now
lucky for me I never say I'm sorry
I do though when Stanford Dean Jenny
Martinez left the classroom after a
lecture she found hundreds of students
lining the hallway dressed all in black
and wearing masks that said counter
speech is Free Speech
so what is counter speech it's the
heckling that drowns out free speech so
their concept of free speech is that no
opposing side ever gets to talk
I thought you had to be married for that
but it's like I always say if somebody
calls you a bully just intimidate him
till they shut the up
anyway as for steinback the diversity
cop she's likely too dumb for anything
else but the thing is she's still got
that job so she's safe that's the
hilarity of the woke industrial complex
doesn't teach you anything but how to
complain about people who are trying to
succeed and no one wants that person in
the workplace
so you need to find a job just like
steinbach's to survive because while
students fail in real life the dean of
outrage still makes a pretty penny
meanwhile elsewhere in California antifa
rioted at UC Davis because a
conservative Charlie Kirk was speaking
[Applause]
that's a lot of woes
of course the faculty stood with the
anti-speech freaks here's the UC Davis
Chancellor
UC Davis stance with our transgender and
non-binary Aggies in opposition to this
hateful and divisive messaging oh how's
this for a divisive message you're a
douche
using his job so he has to the parent
the mob
but once again we see the ludicrous
contradictions right let this belief
speech that makes them uncomfortable is
violence
but that the literal violence that they
unleash in response that's free speech
so why do these students go to college
anyway why go there in the first place
you think they want to succeed in life
but no no one achieves success as a
victim and that failure just makes them
angrier which feeds into their
victimhood it's a self-perpetuating loop
of defeat it's like they want to turn
out like Brian Kilmeade foreign
rest in peace
I'm kidding he's alive God don't die
during the show Brian
but we're seeing this prescription for
failure throughout Society this
d-i-e-b-s creates the appearance of
progress without actually paying
attention to customer needs they'll say
hey look at our wokeness score never
mind that this is a bank and we're
collapsing
and that becomes an incentive for weak
Minds I mean you could do a good job a
really good job and maybe no one notices
or you could display your wokeness and
get recognized without having to work at
all
it gets worse if a recruiter has to
choose between a competent white dude
and the only diversity choice left
because that pool has already been
drained she's going to hire the
diversity leftovers to meet their quota
so companies decline while those who
Embrace Equity over competence manage to
hold on to their job
just like that Dean of equity but it's
everywhere now even Finance Silicon
Valley Bank probably didn't collapse
because of wokism but how does wokism
make anybody want to put their money in
your bank how does any of this stuff
make anybody more trustworthy back in
the day if you opened an account at a
bank they gave you a free toaster now
it's a lecture on pronouns
the most common pronouns that folks are
familiar with are she and he probably
you have clients that use they them as
pronouns they're gender-neutral pronouns
on purpose we talked about folks that
are non-binary that intentionally don't
identify as male or female so some of
those folks use they them as their
pronouns Z is another gender-neutral
pronoun and the other part of that would
be here spelled h-i-r
that was Signature Bank
currently in a lot of trouble
so the bad news is hey you may lose your
house the good news when the movers come
you can call them by the appropriate
pronoun
[Applause]
tonight's guest she knows security like
I know immaturity former deputy National
Security adviser Katie McFarland
[Applause]
as a British conservative he feels
conflicted about driving on the left
best-selling author in Fox News
contributor Douglas Murray
he's exactly what we look for in a guest
available on short notice Fox News
contributor Tom Saloon
[Applause]
small lanky and people scream when they
find her in their bathtub Fox News
contributor captive
Douglas always a pleasure to have you
back on this show
and I'm not paid to say that although I
should be but there's going to be a Bart
yes yes there's always a bud with me and
it's usually firm you know um would you
ever hire one of these people as a
lawyer could you imagine them actually
trying to argue a case in court no it's
terrifying I mean these these most
people think of Stanford is like the
third best law school roughly in America
so yeah these students are going to go
on to Serious careers or should have
gone on to Serious careers and I think
they should all frankly be chucked out
of the University I think everyone
should be fired they shouldn't be able
to work certainly not in the law because
they're just not going to be able to
represent any clients I mean it's going
to be a horrible shock for them when
they discover what crime is yes
um uh that real Pride the real crime
yeah I mean and not just hurty words
yeah but you know Murder stabbing rape
all these sorts of things they're going
to have to be a courtroom Prosecuting or
defending and I just don't think we want
a generation of American lawyers that
runs out of the courtroom for a safe
space but I but there's one other thing
which is that this apology just isn't
enough
I still can't get over the sheer joy of
the fact that the diversity inclusion
and Equity officer is called Steinbach
yeah it's it's great I'm fairly sure
there's a back story there somewhere of
something that somebody could call a
pressure but but miss Steinbach has got
such a great grift going on here however
it should stop and if Stanford is
serious about all of this fire her
tomorrow the idea of this woman had the
audacity to speak over a judge and
pretend that she knew more go fire her
save the salary yeah also
it was planned she had a speech ready
she was she was she was swooping down to
steal the moment right that was you know
this I I read somewhere KT that like
Stanford has them like just the more
inclusivity like uh Consultants than any
other school because they have so many
woke students none of them these are
lawyers understand the First Amendment
that's kind of scary because in 20 years
they're going to be like I don't know
well I guess they'll be waiting on me
they'll be my little handlers
he'll Carry Me In A Box yeah they'll
have to change me KT really yeah even if
I'm healthy
really excites me what
okay have you heard of Chad um you know
gbt yes artificial intelligence how
people in certain jobs are going to be
replaced by computers it's a kind of
scary thought isn't it yes but guess
who's the number one profession that's
going to be replaced by computers
lawyers these people aren't going to be
able to pass there any of the bar exams
but you know what but they'll get rid of
the bar exam well of course is
absolutely racist but but the second
profession is going to go he's
so I'm just I'm just thrilled with this
keep talking you idiots because because
you know
yeah you've got it
yeah we had this discussion if we can
like if I can like online become a
notary you could become a lawyer online
you could become a priest online you can
I've met a few
speaking of priest Tom uh
don't you think it's time to create a
whole new kind of University system I
know there's a University of Austin is
is a kind of openly challenging this
kind of Orthodoxy but uh you're you've
got young daughters right that's right
you have to start thinking about this
Tom's University maybe yeah the sound of
that yeah you're dressed like that who
you yeah exactly you right I need you're
like and you look like what he called a
yell leader not a cheerleader but a yell
leader well look you know what I mean
cricket captain a cricket
I went back to the origins of this
because I wanted to know why why was
this judge so controversially I was it's
amazing was he some kind of shock joke
or something yeah no it's just that he
had a case in front of him it was a guy
named Norman and he got caught with
child porn and he had to go to prison
and then he wanted to go back and he
asked the judge because the this guy
Norman turned into Catherine yes and he
said you need need to go back and you
need to change the arrest warrant to
Catherine and the judge was like no it
was definitely Norman who did that yes
that was his controversy exactly exactly
he caught the grift he was like the guy
was changing his gender so he could get
you know and then he could say no I'm a
woman and I'd go to the women's prison
and then that was his sin yes although
if you are if you're going to change to
Catherine wouldn't you want Norman to
still be the guilty one it's like
instead she's like no no that was Norman
yeah exactly I know it's almost like as
if like Norman Bates was able to
convince the judge that his mother
really killed Janet Lee I understood
that movie oh spoiler alert I've had
plenty of time yes yeah so should we
call you Norman here
good one yeah thank you uh would you you
know you saw what happened to Charlie
Kirk there at UC Davis do you think that
would happen to you
like do you ever think about that when
you're going to speak at a at a college
that did happen to me what are you
talking about in 2016. somebody came up
to me and whipped water in my face and
dumped a whole water bottle in my head I
didn't and I've never had any child porn
you know until you've had somebody
protest you on a college yeah you really
haven't arrived I haven't been here so
for you I'm thrilled
Joe Pat this is why I carry around my
own glass of acid
yeah so if somebody douses water on me
I'd throw acid on him and then I can't
get arrested because they go I thought
it was acid so I had acid with me yeah I
forgot my I forgot mine on the kitchen
table I'm not I'm not sure there's any
law that protects you on that yeah
Norman well
I think that there's something
impressive a little bit here because I
thought you know that nobody could ever
do as good of a job at devaluing a
college education as the government is
doing yeah but these kids are doing
pretty well uh I I mean as you mentioned
Douglas you know to do lawyering a large
the only part of that is being in the
room with somebody with with whom you
disagree that's the only thing that you
have to do and if can't do that you
can't be a lawyer but also you can't
really do anything you know I mean if if
you can't be in within you know I don't
know like 8 000 Acres of someone who you
disagree with without having a total
meltdown I mean I couldn't have survived
when I was working as a Boston Market
cashier it's it's not you can't be a
lawyer you can't go anywhere you can't
move in a neighborhood that's true yeah
but even then nobody's watching them
either yeah
all right
KT going after him you're a monster
tonight yeah you and me and purple we're
gonna paint the town purple tonight
yep all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else